[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
why are you here
to fight
to win
to be a spartan
so
what is a spartan
a spartan is a symbol
where there is none
in times of darkness
we are hopeful
[Music]
and together
together we are unstoppable
candidates are you
ready yes ma'am i can't hear you
again
good
who's first
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey hello everyone what is up welcome
sketch here we are live inside 343
industries in redmond washington i'm
excited to be back
we're ready to talk about our next
multiplayer preview
just got a little taste of the main menu
there i know a lot of y'all have been
talking about it uh much like i we we've
missed that right we've missed the music
we missed the feels but we are nearly
back so thank you for joining us today
we're going to cover off on what you can
expect with our next flight got some
special guests we're going to show off
some new content and kind of give you a
closer idea and a closer look at what
you'll be able to play when this next
flight lands uh before we do that though
i want to give a quick shout out to our
friends uh a lot of folks kind of
noticed the 117 hat some of the cool
apparel that our our friends at the gear
team have been kicking on lately excited
to see we have a special little halo
insider flash promo if you will so for
the next couple hours if you wanted to
go to
gear.xbox.com use
the code halo insider 15 you'll get 15
off so you know holidays are approaching
there's some really cool halo
collectibles there to check out so
thanks to our friends at the gear shop
for helping us out with that
um so we are back
if you were with us for the last tech
preview you kind of have an idea of what
to expect this time um we have obviously
made some progress you'll find that
there's some new things to explore um
teams are working very very hard now on
the road to our launch on december 8th
and we really can't wait to get through
this next critical milestone
our biggest focus for this next tech
preview truly is about concurrency we
are ready to get as many people through
as we possibly can to play at the same
time and our goal is to push our
services and infrastructure as hard as
we can just to help us make sure that we
are ready and able to have a smooth
launch come december now before we get
too much further i wanted to share some
breaking news here because you know the
whole nature of a flight is it's about
helping us discover and work through
problems now versus when it would later
potentially impact you know retail
players once the game is live we learn
something new every time we do a flight
and this is a process that the studio
has been doing
in some cases for years our halo
insiders that have been you know
involved with helping us with mcc know
those flights have been instrumental to
helping that experience improve and
evolve with player feedback in mind a
lot of great uh updates bug fixes
quality of life improvements new
features all those things were the
result of flighting with infinite we've
had small flights going for for quite
some time now and you know back in july
was our first true public flight we
learned a ton there's a big outcomes
blog on halo waypoint if you haven't
seen it that kind of gives you more
insights into what the team saw what
some of the key takeaways were and what
you can expect in terms of next steps on
how we respond to that excuse me respond
to that feedback um but all that's to
say is fighting is still a
process in one moment in development and
there's a lot of fun factors that sort
of feed into that so today um you know i
want to be very transparent that we are
excited for this next preview you know
the selection emails have already gone
out
our hope is that this flight is going to
kick off very very soon officially the
bill was supposed to go out tomorrow
this may or may not happen we are
potentially going to look at a time
shift here we're not quite sure when
it's ready we'll be ready we want to be
very transparent with you though we're
very appreciative of all the insider
support we see out there but
we might have a small shift in our
schedule
and if we do we should have more clarity
on that at some point in the very near
future so we do ask you stay tuned to
halo waypoint stay tuned to halo social
on twitter in particular we will provide
those updates so for now
teams are working very very hard we're
still progressing but we're in a little
bit of a holding pattern due to some
late breaking issues that we found along
the way in this release process so there
is a chance that we might have a shift
in schedule but that doesn't really
change the rest of what we're going to
talk about today which is giving you a
closer look at some of the new content
and some of the new experiences that you
will be able to uh enjoy when this
flight does land
um so today i'm going to first
chat with sarah stern multiplayer
designer about bots we're going to talk
a little bit about how the bots showed
up in the last tech preview and some of
the work that she and the team have done
to further improve the bots and sort of
what you'll expect to see when this next
flight goes live then we're going to
have a conversation about academy want
to show off a new map as part of that
we've got a new experience called
training mode that we're excited to demo
for you here today and then we're going
to wrap things up with our first
official look in detail at big team
battle the new and improved bigger and
better big team battle coming to halo
infinite um that will currently be part
of our second weekend of the flight
but i've got fernando here with me this
afternoon and we're going to take a
closer look and just give you uh
really a firsthand account of a match
that's been played on one of our maps
called fragmentation
so to kick things off i sat down with
sarah stern the other day to talk to her
about bots and the work that's going
into that new feature with halo infinite
so let's take a look at that and we'll
be back in just a few
okay hey everyone we are going to talk
about bots and sarah it is great to have
you on the stream welcome thanks happy
to be here so before we jump into the
nitty gritty and sort of talk about all
the great work in the team have done on
bots can you just tell us a little about
yourself and your role here at 343 so
i'm a designer on the multiplayer team
i'm primarily responsible for bots and a
lot of that is
kind of looking at the game looking at
multiplayer looking at our modes and
making sure that we
with the help of our fantastic engineers
get the bots to
play the game in a way that's
representative of humans
so obviously bots you know huge brand
new addition to halo infinite
multiplayer we took them out for a
preview a little test drive and debuted
those in our technical preview back in
july
landed really really well a lot of
excitement around those but could you
just kind of
walk us through a little bit about the
origin how did how did bots come to be
what what are the goals and sort of
what's the intent that you and the team
had uh when you set out to bring this to
the game
i think uh tom did a really good job of
kind of
setting up the reasoning for why we did
this in our in our last preview when he
talked about how
multiplayer can be kind of intimidating
right it can be
a little bit scary to dive into even
though it's really fun and so the goal
of bots has always been like how can we
make a tool
that allows more people to
experience the fun of multiplayer kind
of where they're at right now
whether that's
i'm just starting the game for the first
time and i'm i'm trying to figure out
the controls or it's you know i had a
rough day at work and i just kind of
want to lean back and
get some medals and have a good time we
just want bots to be there to kind of
expand
when multi-player is available so the
bots made a big splash in the tech
preview um you know i don't know if it's
a good or a bad thing i'm sorry to say
that i'm told that over 65 million bots
were actually slayed during the course
of that of that couple days so suffice
it to say that
they put in some work right and they
landed really really well for the
community but from your perspective you
know
what did you see how how was the
response from your perspective uh any
big takeaways or sort of things that
that you and the team are looking for
coming out of that first tech preview
well i will say for us it was
the response was a little bit
overwhelming you know we've been working
on this feature for a long time and we'd
really only
said that they were in the game but we
hadn't had a ton of feedback yet on it
so it was
it was a lot to go from being very quiet
to having so many people playing with
them
enjoying them giving us feedback on how
they could be better and the team just
kind of ate it up that whole weekend it
was watching people play and really
enjoying it you know they definitely had
some bugs some that we knew about going
into the preview especially with their
movement around maps but the preview
helped us find a lot of things that we
hadn't caught yet or just weren't
expecting like we
weren't sure where the difficulty
stacked relative to the player
population and we got a lot of data that
indicated that
yeah we have some room to make them a
little bit more challenging even though
our goal is to provide an onboarding
experience so just it was a phenomenal
amount of feedback and input that we can
just really kind of put to use to make
them even better yeah the difficulty one
in particular i think kind of
interesting because you know i'll be the
first to admit i think we maybe
we maybe kind of over hyped it a little
bit right it's like oh my gosh the
spartan bots are coming we're super
scared
safe to say that you know the spartan
bots while not meant to be punishing you
know as per your design goals
weren't really
the next level that that i think
you and the team had intended and
certainly not to the extent that we had
overhyped this this big experience for
this next preview one we've bumped the
difficulty kind of across the board
especially because we're now introducing
recruit into the mix so there is another
option for that kind of earlier player
who's wants a lighter experience so the
watch should be a little bit more
challenging this time and we've kind of
flipped on a couple of new behaviors
that we're interested in seeing so
spartans will share some information
with each others as though they're you
know teammates trying to call out
positions so really curious to see how
people react to that we could shift over
like let's talk about a little bit more
you know we have our
an even bigger preview coming up the bad
arena is back um also at some point i'm
pretty sure we'll have a new map added
as well right it's behemoth which we'll
see here in a little bit but it's a
vehicular arena map right so how does
that weigh in when you and the bot team
are sort of approaching the design that
map is interesting you know it's a it's
a much uh
wider experience it's got longer sight
lines than some of our other maps that
you've played on previously and that can
pose different challenges in terms of
you know what bots get engaged in and
what they react to
it there is
bots have some quirks when it comes to
vehicles they
they know that they don't like them but
they aren't sure how to really deal with
them so that's something that we're
aware of but
excited to for people to
get a chance to use vehicles against
some targets and have a good time one of
the things about bots you know that i
think is really cool is you and the team
have done a great job of what if they
just feel natural they feel like they're
really emulating the way real players
play and
at least to me they don't seem cheap
they don't seem like they have
omnipotence or extra health or 100
accuracy um how how did that process
like how hard is it to try and create
these
ai code pieces that seem to model
real-life behavior pretty accurately
and there are parts of it that are
pretty straightforward like things that
are kind of
button presses right like getting them
to shoot getting them to just throw a
grenade is
stuff that halo ai has been doing for a
long time but
where it gets difficult is how do you
represent when to do something when
should i shoot versus when should i back
off when should i throw that grenade
when should i push forward and
we've really tried to have that decision
making from the bot standpoint be
representative of how players at a
certain level think partially so that
people know that they're learning when
they're engaging with these bots right
they they can see bots mimicking
behaviors that they may see in
matchmaking because that's always our
goal is a way to onboard you into
playing against other humans and you can
also see bots make mistakes like a way
to learn is to see someone do something
incorrectly so you can see a bot
especially at a lower difficulty
not disengage when you had its shields
broken so like you can be like okay that
was a mistake and i'm going to take that
knowledge and use it to improve my game
play now you and i talked a little bit
earlier
before this this video about some of the
changes and kind of how bots are going
to show up in the preview two one of the
things i want to touch on briefly is the
bad arena is going to be a little bit
different in terms of
last time you know we had a methodical
we went through the bot progression with
the different difficulty of bots sort of
each day right that's not how we're
doing at this time we're going to have
one bot playlist and i think it's just
going to sort of be a random assortment
of
bot difficulty on each on the enemy team
right
yeah so what that means is that from
match to match you'll have different
difficulties of opponents so you might
play a game and have
a bot team that is two spartans a
recruit and an odst and your next match
might be
against two marines and an odst and a
recruit and and what we're doing there
is we want feedback on what it feels
like to play against mixed teams we you
know we got some feedback from the last
preview that playing against all one
difficulty could feel a little bit flat
and we're also again looking for a bunch
more data on how
these difficulties are stacking against
a wide player audience
and i think you know we're going to talk
about some of the academy additions here
coming up shortly but good news is uh
and one you know not just steal thunder
from our next segment but with the with
the addition of training mode
at that point you can configure the bot
difficulty so if you just want to warm
up against the recruits you can do that
right absolutely if you're
going into the bot playlist and you hit
a couple matches that are a little bit
too intense for you definitely recommend
going into training mode you'll have a
lot more control there over what's
spawning and what kind of difficulty
settings you want to be engaged with so
you know we have talked a lot over the
course of of this road to launch about
how launch is just the beginning for us
and you know that that really applies to
every facet of the game um from the you
know multiplayer all the way down to the
bots as well now
obviously we're in sort of the shutdown
mode here we're in the in game if you
will we don't have that much further to
go you know until we hit our launch date
on december 8th
how are you in the team thinking about
sort of bots going forward and sort of
can you tease anything or just sort of
give us a hint of sort of where where do
you see bots going in future seasons
beyond launch a lot of it is just
looking at what we have in the game now
and
asking questions about how we can take
that to the next level right we we
talked earlier about the you know quirks
they have with vehicles and that's an
active question like how can we improve
their interactions with vehicles
how can we
represent sort of that really high skill
player thinking that we don't have in
spartan necessarily
so that we can provide more warm-up
tools for a broader audience
how can we take
some of the aspects of their difficulty
and make that more customizable so if
someone wants say to disable grenade
throwing when they're practicing like
how can we give them those tools so
just you know thinking through how we
can make it a
more useful tool for people and as part
of that we're going to look at how
people engage with them you know at
launch and that's really going to inform
how we move forward
so sarah before we wrap it up um see any
kind of final words or sort of parting
thoughts on behalf of of the bot team
that you'd like to share with our
community today
i think just thank you like it was it
was so helpful to get all of the data
and feedback we got from preview one and
just
really exciting and motivating to see
people engaging with stuff we worked on
for a while and just excited to get more
of that feedback and appreciate
everyone's time
well i cannot wait to have another round
of insiders even bigger audience this
time go head-to-head with some bots that
have seen some adjustments and
improvements since last time
different difficulties a little mixing
matching as sarah said so we can't wait
to see how you all fare and of course
looking for your feedback to continue
improving as we go forward um we'll be
back in just a minute we're going to sit
down and talk about the academy and some
of the new additions that you can look
for in this next preview be right back
all right we're back uh special thanks
again to sarah for taking some time
earlier this week to talk about all the
great work she and the bot teams are
doing uh to further enrich our halo
multiplayer experience and what you just
saw there by the way
just a little little tease little fly
through of our big team battle match
fragmentation that'll be available on
the second weekend of our upcoming
preview uh we'll talk more about that in
a bit but first i'd like to welcome to
the stream david ellis david welcome
how's it going oh it's going great great
to be back i know you're no stranger to
live streams but you know before we jump
into the academy just quickly who are
you kind of what do you do here at the
studio what's your role yeah so i'm a
senior multiplayer designer i've been at
the studio since 2010 so it was early
days back when uh halo reach uh you were
on youtube
yeah i remember we were we both
supported the reach launch event in fact
we just had the reach anniversary so
good timing there it's been a long time
neither of us had uh gray hair at that
point yeah i'm just i'm quite a bit
hairier
that's fair to say yeah so i've been in
the studio for a long time i've been
working on the game since halo 4. uh i
was focused on spartan ops in halo 4 and
then halo 5 worked on the campaign and
then warzone and
over the last several years i've been
working on bringing the academy feature
set hoping to bring that forward to halo
infinite yeah so you know we won't go
super deep because i know you and the
team have helped us on a number of blogs
we've talked about the academy but just
for
folks that might be joining us for the
first time or didn't play in the last
teg preview what's give us the high
level elevator pitch like what is the
academy how does it fit into the game
and what's what's the kind of the goal
and the intent behind it yeah so i would
encourage everyone to check out the
recent insight infinite blog uh tom does
a great job distilling they're sort of
our key pillars in digging into the why
of the academy i'm just going to give
like the one sentence pitch thing that
i've been saying for years it's like we
want to give players a safe space to
learn how to halo that's really what
it's all about we are franchise it's
been around almost 20 years over that
amount of time there's a lot of
institutional knowledge of people just
assuming you know how x y and z works
you hold a charge on a plasma pistol
it's going to strip someone shields not
everyone's going to know that we wanted
to provide modes and tools and
opportunities for people to be able to
learn that
while they're not getting shot in the
face in multiplayer
and so when we launch uh this year on
december 8th we're going to be featuring
three pillars in the academy we're going
to have a tutorial which is like a first
for multiplayer and halo
and that's going to be a linear
like mission where you're going to
explore the uh avery j johnson academy
of military sciences uh um and you're
going to be introduced to a spartan
commander arena as well and you're going
to have a series of objectives that's
going to onboard you into the world in
universe that halo and infinite takes
place in also give you the opportunity
to introduce all the new uh additions in
halo infinite you're going to get your
personal ai you're going to learn about
all the different equipment and things
like that and and help everyone on board
in that experience and then we have two
other options too we have weapon drills
which we had in the previous check
preview everyone got to check out a
slice of that experience that of course
will be coming back with all of our
projectile weapons are going to be
featured in the weapon drills
and then training mode which players
will get a chance to check out for the
first time in our upcoming tech preview
is another feature and it really at its
core it's an unlimited bot uh slayer
match you get to hop into but then we
have the training options menu layered
on top of it and that lets you play
around with you know play a loadout all
kinds of bot difficulty settings it's
really just a place where you can
explore the entire halo sandbox in a
safe way yeah i you know i'm a huge fan
of the academy we've talked a lot
obviously it was super well received in
the tech preview and you know i know the
goal there is to help onboard and
acclimate players but it also got a
little sweaty during that tech preview
right so if i'm not mistaken you were
putting the call out there for for high
scores and i imagine we'll see people
doing that yet again this time yeah that
was fun and we've actually had a chance
to go back and and check and make some
changes to the weapon drills from that
tech preview as well so i'm excited for
people to get check out some of those
why don't we why don't we jump in i
think you were going to put me on the
spot and make me probably compete and
embarrass myself but yeah i thought it'd
be cool to
showcase weapon drills talk a little bit
about what's changed and then i know for
a fact we have at least one new gun that
we've added this time as well which i'm
sure people would love to check out so
i'll let you drive i'm gonna we're gonna
pick up our controllers no shame in
being a controller player out there uh
we're gonna select weapon drills i think
let's start with the shock rifle which
is a new weapon okay um and it's towards
the top if i recall
yeah it's right underneath the command
rifle so we're gonna play simultaneous
is what we're thinking let's do shock
rifle two shock rifle two i'm just gonna
point out we practiced this yesterday uh
i already have three stars one i played
one time i don't know if i call that
practice i did play we're talking about
practice come on you told me you were in
here this morning like six hours early
grinding on this so i thought it'd be
fun just to like yeah let's both play
simultaneously so shock rifle let's go
and start it up
and
we got right on the same it's perfect
yeah we're in sync you know we also put
out the shock rifle high-res render as
part of the insight infinite blogger
this week it looks fantastic by the way
sorry shout out to our loading screens
yeah the new edition a lot of a lot of
engineers and uh graphics folks have
been working to bring those to life so
that's nice to see so here we are we are
inside the weapon drill so the shock
rifle is kind of a
i would call it more of a medium to long
range
i'm sorry okay no i'm going to then i'm
going to all right here we go so the one
of the cool things with it is if you get
enemies close enough together you can
actually arc the damage and it'll damage
multiple people
yeah i'm not doing good don't watch my
ps4 so what i'm going to do here is just
set up this arc look at this so also by
the way this ducking behavior is new
right they did not duck like this in the
tech briefing so these are the this is
the ducking that's sort of like
pre-programmed and we also have some
dynamic they can crouch when you're
trying to shoot them which should make
the sniper uh weapon drills quite a bit
more challenging you got a little bit of
a little bit of an arc reaction
i won yeah i can see that
although i didn't get three stars i
should point that out as well that we
have retuned all the star score values
and this uh so it should be more aligned
with as you sort of master your skill
level you should be able to move up the
the chain there so a little too easy
last time
it was a little too easy from what the
data we saw and what we saw but kind of
behind the scenes so um i do like by the
way and we the the the arching effect of
that shock rifle is pretty cool it's
enough to kind of weaken nearby
opponents and can make the big
difference right there one bit of advice
i would give you if you're in
multiplayer and you see a group of
spartans one person has the overshield
shoot them first because you're gonna
have more opportunities to arc that
damage image group of spartans because
if you kill someone you can't then arc
off their dead body so i always go
after like the strongest uh strongest
enemy can you tell me that it'll also
arc off the flagpole as well like in a
ctf game yeah so
it's if gameplay especially in btb i
don't want to spoil anything from
fernando segment but if you can get a
really good shock rifle shot you just
see it exploding from across the map you
just see this lightning shooting it
looks like emperor palpatine's going
nuts you said if you get a good shock
rifle shot so i haven't ever experienced
that yet but i'll take your word for it
let's give you a bad shot i thought we
could get going to the s7 sniper as well
sure let's just go right to one of the
hardest snipers and i think we should go
for sniper 3. of course why wouldn't we
because that was the one that everyone
was most excited to put up their high
score so let's uh three two one okay
let's go and these these are going to be
harder targets i assume right yep so
you'll see they dynamically crouch now
which they did it before see it's not
everything's just not on
horizontal plane
uh so it's a little bit different are
you ready oh look quick tip landing
headshots consistently is often the
difference between victory and defeat
who would have thunk it okay here we go
oh god
body shot
missed one oh i missed a lot here i'm
not
it's all about that right reload timing
yeah yeah i'm gonna reload after this
one i'm just gonna try to get my
yeah this is not good i hope no one's
watching my tv
i should have oh that was unfortunate i
should have come in earlier
got 20 seconds left yeah i've only got
like
two kills
maybe three
you know you generally you'd want to
start with sniper one
oh they crouched
i have not graduated to three i'll say
that so one little bit of advice i would
give is when they're
going back and forth if you're also
strafing as well you're gonna move at
the same speed i find that's easier to
kind of hone in your shot and get it
just right yeah i got a new high score
it says look at that that's that's great
that's awesome i didn't even get three
stars that time i need i i needed three
more thousand so like one and a half
more shots i missed quite a bit there
but yeah you know one thing you know i
talked about and i think you we
mentioned this before in the blog as
well you know going forward
seeing the kind of viral competitive
nature that emerged on social last time
something you and the multiplayer team
have talked about in terms of the future
yeah like leaderboards would be a cool
addition leaderboards are absolutely
something we wanted to get them in there
for launch but it didn't quite happen um
definitely if it's something you're
excited about you want leaderboards and
weapon drills you know put the call out
there in the forums and stuff make sure
you let us know because that helps us
align as we're planning future content
as we kind of launch this halo infinite
service
we're partnering with the community
partnering with the players so that
we want to be reactive as much as we can
so if it's something you really really
want call for it and where to see if we
can make it happen i i think it's safe
to say we can just assume leaderboards
are wanted so we'll add that to the list
so we're going to jump over now and take
a closer look at training mode right
which you mentioned briefly i also want
to note that we're going to do like a
this is a double demo here we're not
only going to show off training mode for
the first time but we're going to pick
behemoth our new multiplayer map for
this preview as the backdrop um which
we've i think some folks have seen this
a little bit maybe in the trailer
earlier this year we put some concept
out on monday but
i love this map it's also
brings vehicles back to the arena for
the first time in a while so that's a
really interesting new twist but
uh let's let's turn over to your point
of view here david if you want to kind
of yeah
training mode on behemoth
should go pretty quick
there's a loading screen beautiful
loading screen
and yeah here we are on behemoth which
is a 4v4 arena map with vehicles so as
you said it's super exciting to have
vehicles back in the arena space
to me it just helps bring extra variety
into that 4v4 experience so the first
thing i'm going to do so training mode
it's pretty simple experience once you
get in here and play it it's hard to
kind of communicate it
it's an unlimited box layer match you
can go in any time hit the pause menu
and this is different differentiation
you see this setting here training
options players might have seen a hint
of this before in earlier trailers and
in here you can go in customize your
loadout to whatever you want it to be so
i'm getting myself a sniper rifle
maybe a br as well
uh i'm going gonna go let's stick with
the frag
you can do primary secondary grenades
set the equipment i'm gonna give myself
the grapple shot but because i want to
show off the map i'm gonna go in here
you can set the number of friendly and
enemy bots and that goes you know zero
all the way up to three for friendly
bots or four or four enemy bots uh you
can tweak their difficulty as well
reveal enemy location basically what
this does is it puts a little nav point
marker over every enemy on the map so
you can actually see where they are
through walls that's super useful if you
just want to because the bot behavior is
dynamic you don't actually control it uh
if you wanted to like focus on uh your
accuracy and things like that i found
that to be a really useful tool uh play
fighting is sort of similar to the
experience in the tier three weapon
drills where the bots will engage in
their combat behaviors but they won't
actually shoot at you
i'm gonna leave that off because at
least when i'm playing i like them
shooting at me because if you're getting
de-scoped and stuff you can kind of
learn how to play around that i'm gonna
turn infinite ammo on
uh and you know there's this other
little feature at the bottom we're going
to ignore that that's just you know for
streaming
i don't need that i don't need that it's
just you know just something for the
kids wait so you're on recruit difficult
well you turn the bots off for now the
bots are off right now so i'm just going
to hop over here you see man cannons
yeah let's give the community what they
want i i i i assume people would love to
get a closer look at this map so i think
maybe we want you to give us a little
tour yeah so i'm going to just drive
over here because i found like the
skybox this is absolutely amazing
absolutely gorgeous it's a good mixture
of like this sort of desert terrain
forerunner aesthetic palm trees what
more can you want uh it just it looks
fantastic i love the new kind of
foreigner
aesthetic we're using this game so
the map's kind of like a i kind of see
it it's a little bit of sand trap you
have the aesthetic good vehicle play a
little bit of valhalla with the two
bases although in this case the bases uh
actually face away from one another
but you have this ring on the outside
you can just drive around it's just
fun to do laps help to
pick up buddies on flag runs
it's just it's a super fun space to
drive around i'm also going to pop up
here so give you a little demo showing
off the base there's two levels of the
bases there's a grav lift from the lower
level so man cannons grav lifts warthogs
oh my it's the best halo stuff it's
everything i love about halo and i want
to give a shout out to uh tyler inserud
who was the
level designer on this map he's just
done a great job from the very first uh
take on it i've just fallen in love with
this level so you have this little path
down the middle which is a great
shortcut but sneaky pass but you better
be prepared because you can get shot
from every single angle so if you're
coming down here with a flag
just be prepared
and yeah so this map's just
it's just a lot of fun and i know when
we showed it off for the first time a
lot of players thought perhaps it was a
btp map so
but it's it's designed around 4v4 a lot
of opportunities for you know
using your grapple shots using vehicles
vehicle plays just super great but also
if you're on foot you have a lot of
opportunity for grabbing cover uh and
you know doing your best so i'm gonna
turn the bots back on so we can actually
i can train for a little bit yeah i'm
gonna turn the friendly bots on
enemy bots i mean marine difficulty i
you can do a little better than that
right i think we can let's let's bump it
up spartans as sarah pointed out the
bots are a little more lethal now they
they've they've been training hard since
july as well that's right so the bots
are back and you see they they join i
think i turned the
trying to remember if i turned the uh
the reveal enemy location on let me just
double check that to make sure because i
think that's gonna
help the time to combat come in okay so
now you've got a little extra intel
oh so they just use the shock grenade on
me right i'm gonna return to the back
i'm gonna retreat and run away
by the way you know the same arcing
effect the shock rifle generates that
the dynamo grenade is gonna do the same
thing to the great effect i might add
yep
all right so i'm gonna swap too last
where did you come from
for the record oh yeah i was gonna say i
haven't died but i forgot i said it
i was feeling pretty good about myself
you haven't died imagine that
that first encounter i felt like i
should have uh
died there so i'm just gonna grab cover
here
not doing too good i'm gonna try to
escape they're relentless yes you see
how quickly they're gonna shred my
shields
you know so as i'm just gonna update
something i'll mention something that
sarah spoke to in her segment um you
know once the bada arena playlist is
live in the flight it'll be a it'll be a
mix up of different difficulties on the
opposing squad right so this is great
if you just want to come in here and
warm up by the way you can do it um
lots of opportunities to do that
including customizing the difficulties
they're using the shock right they are
well it's good
that's my favorite thing i don't know if
anyone noticed like i was
they little they were gonna take me down
and i just swapped to make sure i had
rockets and that
always feels good that you have the
upper hand
it's not cheating too it's the mode you
know another thing that we didn't i
didn't really mention at the outset
which we did mention in the blog
yesterday is when the flight does go
live um you know one thing that's going
to be different this time around is
we're going to have specified play times
um yep so we have essentially the plan
is that we'll have two 4-hour windows
each day where matchmaking will be
available
now outside those windows though you
will still be able to play weapon drills
and academy so this the training mode
will be available 24 7 for the duration
of the flight
oh come on that was a pretty good shot
give me some credit for that one that
wasn't bad lift on that one
but it's funny you can just pop in here
you can tailor the experience however
you want i'm gonna use this grab lift
here which is a classic sneaky route
also you get to turn the infinite ammo
not only gives you infinite ammo you
might notice i have infinite grenades i
also have infinite equipment charges
so if you want to live out your arachnid
superhero fantasy you can do that
i'm not gonna do it because i'm not as
good as some of the guys around here
that can basically just grapple all the
way around the map
he doesn't know i have rockets oh
whiffed
are you still deafless i am totally
there's still deafness
it makes me look good though
i feel like the audience might have
forgotten at this point
but this is also a good opportunity i
should point out i'm not doing it here
which is terrible to just learn the map
learn the weapon placements stuff like
that in a way that you know you're in
control of
oh you were
you were definitely super combined there
by the way no doubt about that but yeah
at any point you can go in here hop back
in here adjust anything you want to i'm
going to make myself not deathless so
you can see how quickly i'm going to die
it's going to be painful i feel like
with training mode i could finally maybe
make my own montage of just doing sick
plays
honestly let's see against recruit bots
that's one of the things
i'm looking forward to that i think this
is going to be a place where people can
just really experiment with the sandbox
see how far they can push it and try to
actually do that uh for reals when the
game comes out and do something crazy
yeah by the way they did melt you you
weren't you weren't joking
uh one thing i should mention that uh i
didn't mention weapon drills we have
updated some of the quick tips to do a
better job of communicating weapons with
all fire for example the ravager you can
hold the fire button down and it'll do
damage over time so i think i'm going to
get one more kill yeah one more kill and
then we'll take us out on a high note do
something do something truly epic here
no pressure
i didn't get credit for it but i think
my friendly bot must have gotten the
kill here we go that's a team game right
oh no look at that i'm going to get one
kill pesky [ __ ] i die again we'll call
it and i will exit the stream in shame
i mean we could just keep going we'll be
here all night i don't think anyone
wants that
i just put through the controller that's
a good one i gotta kill a good one to
end on call it there so yeah again to
reiterate training mode will and the
weapon drills for that matter both be
included in this uh upcoming preview
both will be available for play pretty
much all the time from the moment the
build is released all the way until the
time the flight is turned off so
encourage folks to jump in
run it through its paces all the
available maps will be selectable
through the training mode i believe
their behemoth may not come online until
a little bit later similar to last time
we might be staggering some of that
content to kind of keep the experience
fresh but
um suffice to say by you know by the end
of that first weekend you would be able
to jump in and also play behemoth as
well so david before we uh before we
wrap up and switch over to btb
any sort of parting comments or final
thoughts you'd like to share with our
community today well definitely one of
those is people get hands-on with
training mode for the first time always
love ideas like as a designer i want to
know what people like what they don't
like also if there's features that don't
exist in there that would help them i
want to know about that as well because
we'll add it to our backlog and see if
we can edit in there we already have
like a long list of stuff that we want
to do sarah and the bots team have
talked about actually
adding more granular difficulty controls
to training mode maybe you can do
different difficulties on your friendly
bots enemy bots
really make it a whole sandbox you can
experiment play also maybe
down the line we want to allow you to go
in with friendly human teammates in a
training mode that's something we want
to do
down the line so we're just excited for
people to get hands-on and see how they
use it cool well i'm excited as well i
can't wait in fact you know one thing
i'm going to do in training mode right
away i don't think i personally really
got my sensitivity dialed in last time
it's a little bit different in this game
right so
training mode is a perfect opportunity
for me to kind of tweak a little bit
take some shots and kind of do that in a
safe environment and sort of
hopefully improve my game by the end of
this next preview i've seen people do
that weapon trails on the last tech
preview and i think that's like
last thing is i'll just close out that
there's a clear progression we kind of
think about as we're onboarding players
kind of start with the tutorial go to
weapon drills go to training mode then
bot arena and at that point you should
be fully prepared for matchmaking and uh
and you know playing halo infant with
your friends or starting ranked if
that's your if that's your fancy right
yeah that's also an option for you not
me
well thanks david for the academy update
here uh this will be coming out soon in
the preview uh coming up next we're
gonna be joined by fernando and we are
excited to show you uh the first look at
a match of big team battle on
fragmentation we will be back in just a
minute
okay we're back you just had another
little uh
ambient fly-through of fragmentation i
want to give a huge shout out to the
audio team i mean i've had a lot of fun
playing that map and it's very bombastic
in the heat of the moment and i just the
first time i've really been able to
appreciate some of those ambient sounds
so a lot of depth in leia there but
please join me in welcoming fernando to
the stream fernando good to have you
it's great to be here representing the
amazing work that the mp team has done
for btb so uh before we jump into btb
just for folks who who don't know you
who aren't familiar with you uh what's
your role on the team what's your
history with 343 yeah of course i am i
am a senior multiplayer designer i am
part of the
multiplayer design team and i'm one of
the designers working in victim battle
making sure that it's great and it's
exactly as we remember and even better
than that well i know you're doing
fantastic work obviously the community's
super excited about the return to big
team battle i know we've talked a lot
about it we mentioned the inside
infinite blog earlier which you can find
on halowaypoint.com but um from your
perspective just kind of what is the
what's the overall kind of elevator
pitch how how did you and the team
approach big team battle and
specifically when you knew it was going
to come back it's been improved and it's
different so i'm just kind of curious
what are the goals and kind of how do we
end up with what we have today yeah for
sure i think like a little bit of
history here like right at the beginning
when we started thinking about bringing
big btv to um
to halo infinite uh all the designs
we're going to the room and we just like
share our experiences with with btb
right like like exciting moments that we
have or like good memories of a lan
party or something you know like just to
make sure that we're really capturing
that essence of btb
and like after that we came up with
these three very important design
pillars for us that we hope that every
match
of vtv is respecting or is is paying
tribute to
uh so the first one is having uh
embracing really really the spartan
battle fantasy uh it's the thing that is
important for us across the whole
multiplayer i would say but i think it's
especially important in in victim battle
we really want people to
feel like they are like in a real combat
scenario with a spartan unit right a lot
of things going on and like uh having
the pelicans draw vehicles have key
moments in the match that adds
excitement and i think like for maybe tv
is all about like those
special moments that happen uh
thanks to the sandbox right and uh which
kind of leads to the the next point
which is it's a very sandbox driven
experience right it's a space in halo
where you have the full sandbox at your
disposal vehicles weapons
and all of this like in a big setting
with 12 versus 12 players it just leads
to like crazy crazy moments and you know
like just seeing how those different
pieces interact with each other like
grappling shot at um
at a wasp in the air is like a super
awesome moment or like a stopping a
grenade with a repulsor you know like
it's just it's just incredible to see
how we just like put the toys there and
then just
like phone emerges out of it
and finally i think and this is one of
the most important pillars for me is
that
btb should be the social space
i think that we should let and empower
all the different player archetypes that
we might have in halo right so from
people that are like super focused on
shooting and they're like great good
sniper and to people that might be like
more of a driver right or or like myself
that i love to like sneak in and get
like the the the flat cap and uh you
know like we want to make sure that
there's a space
where people can have fun with their
friends right it's a great space to
bring new new players into into playing
multiplayer right like you put them to
like the tutorial and the academy a
little bit and it's like okay we're
ready to go let's go right and let's
play together right like you just drive
me first and then like slowly make them
comfortable with playing halo right
because i think i think it's it's all
about like having fun together right and
having 12 players on each side of the uh
of the match it just it just creates
this space yeah it it is super fun
that's i mean i don't know how else to
describe it also i just want to say
thank you for embracing the shenanigans
archetype which is kind of really my mo
i i don't i'm not even a good shooter
anymore but
my shenanigans are in full effect in btv
and it's super fun now we
recorded a match just the other night
right and i i believe this is your point
of view so no pressure i know you
weren't sorry guys this is not a sweaty
pro match like you said yourself it's
about fun it's about a social experience
um this is kind of raw gameplay this is
recorded on a pc yes um this is not a
trailer i also just want to give
additional caveats this is from our
preview build so you know we're not done
the team continues to work and
i'm really excited and proud of all the
great work that's gone into this and the
progress that's been made but you know
just suffice it to say we are still in
pre-release so i think with that um
we're going to roll this match at ctf on
fragmentation
we had 12v12 we are not going to try to
cast this i promise you but we're going
to let it run for a few minutes to kind
of let it establish itself let our
audience get get a better um
sort of hear and see what btb is about
and then i think you and i can just chat
a little bit and i'll ask you to kind of
share some thoughts and point some
things out about the map and about the
gameplay and just kind of help give our
community maybe an edge for when btb
does come in the second week of our
upcoming preview so for sure uh josh
when you're ready if you want to go
ahead and roll this footage let's check
out some gameplay of ctf on
fragmentation
capture the flag
capture enemy flags to score
we attacking or defending
the next one
another one
please
okay so we're gonna let this keep
playing here fernando but uh for folks
that maybe missed the intro this is
sketch joined by a multiplayer designer
senior multiplayer designer fernando
here in the studio
giving you a first look at ctf on
fragmentation one of our new maps that
will be in this preview brandon i'll
turn it over to you a little bit um
we saw a chaotic opening there by the
way those two warhawks just head to head
right out of the gate but feel free to
kind of point out some stuff and uh you
know just just share a little bit with
us some additional context about what
we're seeing yeah i think first of all
like i would like to talk a little bit
about the map right like fragmentation i
this is one of my favorite maps in in
btv for infinite it has that like
400 steady feels like almost like a
campaign level right and uh and it gives
me that bachala vibes too you know so
it's like i uh as a as a big halo halo
fan it's it's just exciting to play on
it
um
yeah like so big big shout out to uh
cliff schultz that is the level designer
of this
of this map he he did an amazing job
with it
um
yeah that was a skewer right there
but yeah i think that we're playing ctf
right now
we have done some tuning especially for
for btb in terms of
how ctf plays right compared to arena
i will not give a lot of details on that
i hope that people like get to play it
and and and see it in person uh
but yeah we we try to make it uh
uh just to uh
embrace really like collaboration and
teamwork uh so so everyone everyone
feels good while playing like one of my
mantras while working in btv has been
like everyone should feel like a hero in
every match
right like you should have like a cool
moment that you feel like oh man i'm i'm
amazing right i'm great at this game and
and hopefully like ctf does that for
uh for people um
this is a cool thing i think to
to to mention about the map we have this
thing that we internally call the loot
cave
right where you can bring your uh
bring your ai and hack the the entrance
to the loot cave
and uh yeah you just have to like be
careful there and like escort it while
uh your little guy does its thing um
it's just a sub objective right yeah
it's just a sub objective it doesn't
have whoever gets here first gets the
loot essentially yeah exactly right it's
just like an interesting way of bringing
more power into the match and getting
cool toys to play right like i just like
picked off the
uh the gravity hammer there and and
the overshield
so let's let's let's see like find find
some people there uh to use my new toys
with right you got all the toys right
now yeah
oh that guy escaped yeah he got lucky
there speaking of which too i think uh
by default you guys talked about scaling
the experience a little bit
i believe equipment has like something
like the grapple has more charges in a
big team battle than it would in arena
yeah right yeah for sure like we figured
that given the extra space right like
this square footage of the maps it would
be nice to be able to play with the toys
a little bit more than just like the
the amount of charges that you would
have in arena
and it plays really well right like
especially like if you have the grapple
shot you can just like swing around and
have fun with it for for a bit uh and
that's that's pretty pretty incredible
oh you're really going to take this
thing all the way back on fire yeah okay
you got a little pick up here yeah i
always like to like um
dry the flag and just like don't have to
walk all the way to the base and
getting a driver which
i don't know like i think this is a good
also moment to talk about how vehicles
play in into into btv right like i think
they are
they're there to uh to be used but i
would say that they are very
incorporated into how the mold plays
uh you'll see that the razorback can
interact with the flag for example
and they're just like a core a core part
of of btb so very very big
shout out to to brian berryhill our
vehicle designer uh
that he hid an incredible job to make
the warhawk and the mongols feel the way
it's supposed to feel it it hurts me to
see you lose that hammer after all the
trouble you went to hack the cave i'm
not i'm not sure you got to kill with it
oh my god i got a good one yeah
oh it's so nice to be back in the man
cannons
this is the commando rifle
which is really pretty cool weapon
mid-range right like i always put it in
between the assault rifle and the battle
rifle in terms of like the role it takes
when you're when you're like in a
combative scenario so so i believe some
vehicles will kind of spawn at each base
by default right but then in addition we
have this dynamic element where
pelican's going to fly in periodically
and drop off vehicles as well yeah
that's a completely new system that we
added for uh
for btb and infinite we have like
pelican drops uh bringing vehicles at
like key moments of the match right to
like
uh there's like some very smart things
running on the back to make sure that
we don't affect the balance of of the of
the match uh
again big shout out to patrick brain and
that he's an awesome designer that make
it happen both both that and the loot
cave too right so
he has been he has been creating cool
cool stuff to make btb really shine and
and make it make it bigger and better
than what it was
and we also have this dynamic element of
these ordinance drops as well i don't
know if we've seen one yet in this film
right but periodically
just cool weapons are going to rain down
from the sky right
yeah yeah so you you can be just like
wandering around in the map and out of
nowhere like uh
an ordinance drop falls right in front
of you which is one of my favorite
animations in the game right like you
just like walk to it and it explodes and
it shows you like your new toy
uh
and it's it's it's it's a good
encouragement for people to just be
scavenging around and walking in the
space right uh i think that btb really
shines is that you have like different
pockets of interaction right like maybe
like this corner we are like playing
with the objective
and like trying to defend the flag right
but maybe in a different corner
somebody's having like a super intense
combat or like somebody else is like
trying to uh stealthy uh
hug the the loot cave for example right
so there's a lot of moments and there's
a lot of things going on in a in a btv
match so it's it's super exciting no
matter where you are
hey was that loot cave does that respawn
at any point during the match or is that
kind of a one and done no it respawns
you have to let it reboot uh it reboots
for a bit and then you can you can go at
it again
oh man you really are the flag runner
huh i love i love running the flag man
like
it's just it's such a cool moment when
you like you know you cap it and it
explodes and you know like you are
contributing meaningfully to
like the outcome of the match it's just
so cool you know and like i don't know
ideally like
like it's a it's a team team based game
right so even if you don't bring it like
you just bring it to the 50 yard line
and then it's like it's up to somebody
else you know and and keep like
moving it like little ants in the match
that's that's the thread sensor right
there like just
putting putting in one there just in
case somebody wants to get close to the
loot cave right you can
i usually like to use it like that right
like behind a wall and maybe like i can
see somebody like
crouching behind or something before i
commit to a route
really kills match
now something else i was gonna we could
mention real quick too i know we're
watching ctf but um
in the preview we're gonna have uh btb
slayer btb ctf and also a new game mode
called total control yeah
yeah for sure oh here here's the pelican
drop look at that
so cool
gets me every time
uh yeah so in terms of modes we we
really try to have like a variety of
experiences in the
in the btb
part of multiplayer
uh like from like very classic btb
uh
slayer experience right it's like how
you remember it you know just like kill
the enemy team right to like an
in-between an improvement on something
like ctf like i was mentioning right uh
to like something completely new like
total control uh total control is a area
control mode
where you have to capture three
different zones at the same time to
score
uh once you score
once once you score one point uh a new
set of zones is selected
uh in different parts of the map to add
some variety and the first team that
does that three times wins the match
it's it's super it's become one of my
favorites it's it's it's just so hectic
because it just forces everyone into
sort of those three there's just a lot
of intense combat because everyone's
kind of switched together trying to get
those zones big fan of total control
oh here we go oh oh man so close huh
oh but it looks like there it is it's a
win you and your team prevailed i'm sure
that your uh your multiplayer colleagues
did not go easy on you for the sake yeah
everybody everybody sometimes like plays
a little bit a little bit good
but that was uh your first look at
capture the flag on
fragmentation like we said that will be
part of our multiplayer preview
currently with our original plans that
would be coming in the second weekend so
we
most likely will have a double header
approach first weekend's going to be
more focused on arena second weekend
we'll be uh introducing btb so stay
tuned you will get a chance to play that
i promise um now fernando before we wrap
this up um
anything else you'd like to say or sort
of final final words or closing comments
you want to share with the community
today
yeah of course
i think that
i just want people to know that the mp
team really cares about halo right and
we are all big big fans of the franchise
so we really try our best to make this
halo game the best ever we put our
hearts into it so we really hope that
people uh are going to enjoy it in this
flight and whenever uh
we
we launched the the full game
uh and yeah i hope you enjoy btb and
share share your clips with us you know
like of all these amazing moments
happening on
on screen
well i'm sure we will get a lot of good
moments out of here plus you know we'll
be out there playing too right so maybe
definitely maybe i'll be able to get in
your squad my shenanigans plus your flag
running i think we could do we could we
could do big things together yeah um so
we're going to kind of wrap this thing
up here um you know as i said at the
outset for folks who maybe missed it
we are
moving towards our next technical
preview for multiplayer pre-selection
emails did go out earlier this week to
halo insiders we are currently in a bit
of a holding pattern um due to some
late-breaking release issues
which may or may not result in a shift
to our current schedule uh i will get an
update once we're done with this stream
here today i ask folks just to keep an
eye on halo waypoint
we will be providing a lot more
information
um about the flight including all the
instructions and play times and things
of that nature
additionally you know always a good idea
to follow halo on twitter for real-time
updates there
but either way this flight in our next
preview will be coming uh fairly soon
we're very excited to have everybody to
jump in and uh and help us really push
our services to the limit and
concurrency again is our number one goal
which is also by the way why this time
around we are going to be focusing on
two
specific place sessions two four hour
windows i mean that's to really help us
drive max players at the same time to
help us hit those numbers
and it also by the way it gives the the
services folks for example some a window
to be able to do some work as well
without impacting the live experience
for all of our flight participants i
also just wanted to add that for that
second weekend that i mentioned when big
team battle goes up um we're looking to
go even bigger and we will be removing
some barriers and kind of widening the
funnel as a way to bring even more
people in so if you didn't get an
invitation to the first weekend don't
fret there will be additional chances
for xbox insiders to be able to join
kind of on the fly
via the xbox insider hub and we're also
going to look at a way to distribute
additional steam keys
along the lines of allowing pc players
to invite a friend for that second
weekend so those details will be coming
soon to halo waypoint so stay tuned for
that
and with that you know appreciate
everybody's support halo insiders
especially
uh from the earliest days of the mcc
sort of update road and journey all the
way to where we are today we would not
be here without you your support your
participation your feedback absolutely
is helping the studio absolutely helps
us make these games better um and this
doesn't stop at launch you know even
feedback that we got in july is already
helping to inform
opportunities and things to go after for
for beyond launch because launch is
really just the beginning in a lot of
ways so and i think i just saw it pop up
on screen but just a quick reminder we
do have our special 15 off insider deal
going on at the gear shop using
code halo insider 15 i think that's
going to go for another
hour or two um 5 p.m pacific so you
still got some time to want to pick up a
new halo hat or t-shirt check out the
gear collection there from our friends
at the gear shop
and that's it then for now so on behalf
of everyone at 343 industries thank you
for watching thank you for joining the
halo insider program we will have more
information about when the bill will be
released and we look forward to playing
with you online very soon thanks so much
why are you here
to fight
to win
to be a spartan
so
what is
where there is none
in times of darkness
we are hopeful
[Music]
and
together
together we are unstoppable
candidates are you ready
who's first
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you